hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights some went
squish sure what it was anyway someone
might have pointed out something that
there was a key of some sort on some
hahahaha well what do you know I didn't
even know that was the right room um
restroom mr. Sylvester here
he's dick restroom nope
that's what's wrong ok back Blanc yeah
up it dude yeah I've no idea where the
restroom would be into it not enough how
do you just turn it off it's not that
dark in here I mean it's pretty dark but
it's not crazy nerd oh no I did I use oh
it might I might have used the wrong key
I forgot that I have
all right hang on
the restroom Kiana let me check the
middle key our middle room here
ah yeah I use the wrong one sorry folks
[Music]
oh boy oh oh god damn okay this room is
freaky looking
hello chair please help me oh wow
I don't like this at all it looks about
the freakiest from I've ever seen in my
life
hello dead guy
whoa Oh some coming up on me
driver gimme gimme all right switch whoa
okay all right there's weird egg things
on the ceiling not sure about what
that's all about
no no no oh no no no I don't know sack
of potatoes pills here and this isn't
exactly a restroom I just want to point
that out that guy's not at rest it's
only called a restroom in America called
a washroom in Canada and most likely
other names in other countries
okay all right I think there's anything
else in here
still locked sure come in Wampus okay
did that like ten power onto the
computer or something
hello buddy no okay all right dude just
go on Munger would so likes one of these
pop machines moveable II no um okay then
oh right here all right oh I see I got
you
we're good we're good doing good my
timer gives you the Wonder
don't like is either
[Music]
who's that I really like it I thought he
was like ah
where where where I can't move
why can't I move that way gotta go for
the yellow one I was about to say and
actually now I'm convinced that he's
doing a real good job of keeping the
monsters away for a bit because he was
doing a lot of monsters and now he's
keeping the monsters away so that I'm
like a monster a monster is that about -
ah I need a run back you do you guy
can't come this way is your dick hello
got three and your face you're an
[ __ ]
I was wondering flow I slammed that door
shut with fervor what's going on okay
I'm okay with that I'm okay with not
going in there hi Billy Mays here
okay
okay okay I can leave now thank you
thank you guy whoever pointed out where
the key was I don't know how I missed
that because I went in the room I swear
I looked at everything but apparently I
did not
it's like really quiet I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know it's so quiet
and so dark did you what was going on
here all right stick this [ __ ] in was
with these pop machines
do I stick these rods in oh in the back
here no breathes one two three jam it in
there do something else here
maybe if I do get I do have a
screwdriver now ah buy a smaller box
okay alright well we're here because is
where all the weird switches were it is
like so quiet I don't know what's going
on
here we go here we go here we go there
we go okay now this is one two three so
I'm guessing one what come on it's right
there front of your face one going on
this why is it so quiet
wait ooh okay
oh come on what the hell's going on here
nothing nothing really good dig around
with me give me nothing all right what
the hell no object to use it on don't
know what that's all about but whatever
I still have this tomb door key
maybe there's something I'm still
missing don't say anything
find all the parts to make it work again
maybe I am missing something maybe I
need to like get something the tomb key
the true key that's gotta be something
right I mean I have no idea maybe down
in the middle I did remember that down
in the middle here I missed a part or I
didn't
Oh Oh can't see [ __ ] Isis door open is
so dark
where the break of fracas is - I need
oil let me double check in here I don't
think there was much in here but please
be brave okay lighter something I mean I
got the tomb key in here I have to
assume that there's something oh oh oh
haha yeah maybe this okay Oh was this
while working on the project we found a
hidden temple deep underground it was a
disturbing place woth weird noises
some of the workers found remains of
dead people's bones notice covered in
blood I can't read it
there must be yeah I know I know I know
about this this whole deal with the rug
and all that but I don't think I want to
go down there and waste time if there's
nothing there
Wow
what what the hell I just fell through
the grate are you kidding me kidding me
whatever let me out buggy buggy I'm
gonna going down there at least didn't
hurt me all right
- must be somewhere else where was it -
I don't know I don't know oh alright
time to stop tagging like such a big
baby
maybe the tomb isn't anything and maybe
there is just nothing else and I need to
just get them right in the holes I don't
know no after the door isn't gonna be a
giant douche bag where is it there it is
there's gotta be something I mean what
am I doing wrong why is this grabbable
wonderful possibly be doing this why why
why won't these fit in there right there
in front of my face yo ism
gosh darn it oh okay I don't know I must
be doing something wrong if it didn't
push a button what's that 100 here one
can't use this item this way it says 1
all right 1 over 1 then 3 2 okay how
does that help me do I stick them in
here
there's
ah ah
what are these mean so one it doesn't
highlight it doesn't light up there's no
place for this none at all
okay one mom's feeling so dumb right now
I feel so dumb
I feel like uber mega ultra dumb okay oh
man freaka frack
frazzle dazzle there must be something
I'm missing
there must be let me go hunting for the
tomb all Gus so dark where's the door
where's the damn door where's the damn
door oh god why is it so dark it's a
power down I thought I'd turn to Oh
Cassie [ __ ] I thought I'd turn the power
on in this little room here devices was
spinning wasn't it yeah it's spinning
let's go
thunk her chunk oh I did not like
anything okay I got a hunt for the two
in the dark oh boy let's try going back
a bit if not the two must be down in the
depths somewhere I can't even go back
that's the only place it could be right
down in there must be I don't know let
me double-check dark quiet
unsettling it's unsettling settle unning
it's less than settling
the scariest gamers of the scare other
games to make you scare yourself true to
life less money you see a monsters this
is more scary they are get out of the
way I'm gonna fall down look like it
ain't nothing okay there must be
something here he's gonna hurt okay
there's got to be something down here
right right I can't see anything numb
got blood in my eyes this is the
computer that's where the key was dark
why is it dark here - was not dark here
was it was it I suddenly everything dark
got the toon key from there can't use it
on that door the only other way out is
going back up so lost I need being lost
I need to get this box I can't see a
damn thing
shut up weird steam pipe squeezing let
me in let me in let me in let me [ __ ]
in there we go there's nothing else it's
obviously not down here maybe oh ah damn
you damn it maybe I'm out of time anyway
so I'll get my hypothesis for the next
one so thank you all so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next part bye-bye